this pizza chain is trying to increase
customers appetites not for pizza but
for protection
against covid19 it's planning to offer
a free slice to anyone who gets a
as jacked of a government-led initiative
to boost vaccine uptake
among the young if that is the
difference somebody who is
tight on time uh to come and get their
job then yeah we're happy to give them a
slice of pizza when they've had their
job
absolutely it's more of a a way to
sweeten the deal really rather than some
sort of discount
it it really is for us just the right
thing to do the department of health
says around a third of under 30s
still haven't received a first dose
despite being eligible
that's equivalent to nearly three
million people who'll now be offered
various incentives
i think it's like a funny concept to
think that
this is what young people do just for
vaccine like it's like dangling a
carrot in front of a donkey i don't feel
like it's that urgent i don't really
mingle like that
a lot of close quarters environments i
work from home
as well um i just wanted a pizza
might sweat it might yeah especially if
it's a big one so a large one
go for that ride-hailing apps like uber
and bolt
are also part of the scheme offering
discounted journeys to passengers who
receive a vaccine
app users will also be offered free
rides to vaccination centers to make it
as easy as possible for young people
to get a jab but there are questions
over whether incentives like these
are really the right approach
some scientists fear the strategy could
backfire believing the various carrots
and sticks
will just create confusion i think you
could easily alienate people i mean what
we've got to do i think is have much
better messaging to the
to the to younger folk about the
benefits of vaccination for them
personally
and for the people around them and be
very clear about that messaging
um rather than trying to bring in you
know vaccine passports by the end of
september for access to
to various venues etc but at this stage
it seems the government's keen to try
every strategy it can
hoping this will provide the nudge that
some people need
iva bennett sky news